following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand the seven defining attributes
that make you special today we will
focus on strength in the wasteland
essential supplies will be scarce when
an item of value is found keep it close
and away from bullies the stronger you
are the more you can carry be sure to
know your limits where you may find it
challenging to escape from hazardous
scenarios no matter how strong you are
there are other situations where you may
find yourself in close proximity to
unfriendly neighbors for such cases you
must learn to defend yourself using your
natural strengths use anything sharp or
sturdy enough to swing get creative with
your implement but stay reasonable
and for anything that can further
enhance your innate vigor the greater
your strength the greater the impact but
remember some moments require more than
muscle keep doing your chin ups and push
ups because there's more strength can do
for you swing for the fences like the
pros crafting specialized protective
gear to keep your building clever
weapons to wield it in this chapter we
focus on perception it is the
unfortunate truth that when you go above
ground you will be faced with many
post-nuclear nuisances these frightening
menaces will come in all different
shapes and sizes and pose an immediate
threat to your survival you must learn
to deal with these dangers but may find
this challenging at first
that's why we've provided you with the
vault tech assisted targeting system so
you can scan the threat and pinpoint
areas of weakness and the higher your
perception the more accurate you will be
while you'll put Davy Crockett to shame
there may be times when you must engage
in questionable activities your
perception can help keep you safe during
these morally ambiguous moments practice
your pilfering on youths the elderly or
the incapacitated as you continue to
purloin your way to success try more
challenging targets and more skillful
techniques for greater returns
don't get too cocky there sport
always look to sharpen your five senses
for perception doesn't stop there
keenly assessing the unfriendly locals
and terrain handling sensitive munitions
with blend building a long distance
relationship our topic today is
endurance we will all be faced with many
new and unfamiliar health risks such as
infection sudden loss of limb and above
all harmful radiation fortunately your
formidable endurance has turned your
body into a hard-working machine that
can resist the harmful effects of
radiation and physical violence like any
machine then your body must be
well-maintained to stay in tip-top shape
while average joe's will survive on old
packaged standbys your ironclad insides
will allow you to seek fresh meat
radiation poisoning may have enlarged
your favorite meals
this means more healthful nutrition for
you take caution not to bite off more
than you can chew endurance can also
provide new options for food some of
which can be an acquired taste
gone are the days of exercising for fun
instead you will need to combine
athletics with crucial survival
activities the greater your endurance
the further you can go just be certain
to be mindful of others build your
endurance and soon you will find ways
that it improves your life above ground
I've added confidence in the swimming
pool stronger more resilient limbs to
cause the flesh of your fellow man can
travel and now charisma what is it made
of
unlike the clean wholesome America you
may recall the wasteland will be a
distrustful place full of unsavory
characters and a few more E's earning
the trust of your fellow man is an often
overlooked key to survival one way to
prove your trustworthiness is through
fair commercial exchange your renowned
charisma will enable more favorable
bartering don't get greedy now use your
charismatic nature to negotiate your way
out of tense moments having friends is
always of value how else do I find
friends you may wonder you may find an
impromptu cocktail hour helps to ease
social stress your charisma will help
you avoid the perils of addiction but
not the immediate effects of drink so
practice moderation
or you'll find out who your real friends
are the hard way you will find that even
wild animals can be charmed by your
charisma looks like you found a new pal
bull don't get carried away there big
fella
oh so you see taking the charismatic
approach is more than just good manners
working with man's best friend - more
loyal companions with vinson others to
act on your behalf
our next area of attention is
intelligence with all the talk of
physical survival in the wasteland you
may forget that sometimes it's survival
of the smartest an empty mind is a
vessel for knowledge and intelligence is
the key to unlocking opportunity and
adapting to your new world above ground
your advanced know-how will grant you
access to new places and new
technologies space age isn't it
intelligent survivors are also more
inventive creating technological wonders
of their own note that the s in science
stands for safety and when the tables
are turned against you don't be afraid
to set aside your refined intelligence
for the raw instincts of survival just
don't lose your head advanced learning
in the field of intelligence can offer
even more benefits in this modern age of
wonder to start navigating with
technological ease keep blood where it
belongs by here and in creating more
potent chemical compounds from now let's
discuss the uses of agility a nuclear
blast and the subsequent fallout will
have many adverse effects on life as we
know it intensive prolonged radiation
exposure may transform those above
ground into decrepit rotting beings that
have lost their ability to reason they
will likely be without common manners
and quick to anger
you must learn to make the most of
available firearms enthusiasm will only
take you so far
now let's try that again and remember
that with your impressive agility you
can act more decisively in advance see
it's a snap agility can also help you
out in difficult moments but why place
yourself under undue stress instead try
a simpler route taking the quieter
approach is always worth consideration
your agility can turn a sneak attack
into a complete tactical move keep in
mind others may have the same bright
idea your agility will help you move
through the wasteland with ease and
yield other benefits like assaulting an
unsuspecting dreamer for the king in
hastily reloading your firearms
propelling on damage to additional
targets when the firm got your rabbit's
foot good it's time we talk about luck
the difference between whether you live
or die in the post nuclear world may
depend on the flip of a coin
luck is a mysterious sort of curiosity
see here the well-placed shot may not
always do the trick if Lady Luck favors
you though you'll find those critical
moments a breeze what's this
only scrounging up duds time and
patience may net you a suitable
collection but with luck on your side
you're bound to find some swell keepers
no no hold on to anything shiny it may
be of hidden value be careful not to get
distracted by your newfound fortunes oh
that wasn't the only test it looks like
luck has helped you once again
unfortunately she can't save you from
every situation
at least your misfortune can become
someone else's fortune
look maybe fickle but if you can woo her
to your side the possibilities are
endless a particularly bloody mess will
look a chance to build a streak of
destruction that got the magic of the
unexpected all regularly sunny your tech
provided materials to prepare for
survival and to answer the question do
you know what makes you special